I got involved while I was still a law
student at the University of Miami and I
was taking an international law class
and just remember feeling outraged that
Washington policymakers were debating
the legality of these medieval torture
techniques which you know back in the
day it was called Chinese water torture
and today in America it's waterboarding
and beyond that the men who had never
been charged of anything criminal were
being rounded up and arrested and held
seemingly indefinitely and they weren't
afforded the same rights that any
alleged rapist or murderer in America
receive and so that was my initial
interest and how that was sparked and I
ended up googling the cases that I was
studying and found out who the attorneys
were that had taken the Guantanamo cases
to the Supreme Court and I got in touch
with them and got my foot in the door as
an interpreter for habeas counsel
because I speak Pashto which is a major
language in Afghanistan